Where my shorties at?
I have some good news--from science!
We shorties are better than everyone.
Especially the tall ones....That's all you
need to know.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
You know, short guys take a lot of crap.
One of my best friends growing up was about
the same height as me, 5'2'', and was bullied
constantly for it.
For ladies, it's reversed right?
If you're too tall you're more likely to be
the target of teasing and bullying.
Height is one of many gender roles we have
here in the Western world.
And if you ask me, that's friggin stupid,
because PEOPLE COME IN ALL SIZES AND WE HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER OUR HEIGHT.
Didn't they ever read doctor suess?
A person's a person no matter how small!
Or large!
And for the record, short people can get around
all quick like and do some real damage so...I'm
just sayin....shortness is the bomb.
Don't believe me?
I'll let the science do the talking then.
A whopping 40 year long study recently published
in PLOS-1 monitored over 8000 Japanese-American
men throughout their lifetime and found that
being short means living a longer life.
The scientists found, with great consistency,
that the taller the man, the shorter his life.
Those under 5'2'' lived the longest.
Why do the shorter guys live longer?
It all comes down to a gene: FOXO3, which
is responsible for a smaller body size and
is also responsible for longevity.
The two go hand in hand, genetically.
Scientists also found that the short guys
were less likely to get cancer and to have
lower blood insulin.
It's good news for my fellow shorties -- and
this isn't the first study to come to this
conclusion.
Another study done in 2012 on another isolated
population of men found that the shortest
in the group lived about 2 years longer on
average.
Having a sample that comes from the same cultural
and genetic background is really great from
a scientific perspective because it eliminates
a lot of other variables that could come into
play and affect the results.
These findings have also surfaced in studies
of short women - although the studies on women
were related to a different genes involved
in the regulation of human growth hormone.
Across other animal species, like mice, flies,
roundworms-- the same or a very similar gene
has also been linked with a longer life.
It's interesting because it offers some perspective
on the whole nature versus nurture question
about living a long life...it may be less
in our control than we think.
But, as if they saw the tidal wave of junk
food and sitting around coming in the distance,
the scientists did tell the press that a healthy
lifestyle also goes a very long way toward
living a long life.
Alrighty folks, how tall are you?
Have you ever been teased for your height?
Tell me your stories down below and stay tuned
for our next Dnews update.